in an alternate 1980s world war iii has
already commenced and russia back then
known as the soviet union is winning and
expanding their armies they have taken
over major parts of europe and are now
heading west towards north america the
opening scene starts in the american
city of kalume where a boy named jed
drives his younger brother matt and his
friend to the local high school later as
the history teacher is conducting the
class he notices several troops landing
by parachute outside the school the
soldiers have also brought heavy
weaponry with them and they appear to be
speaking in a foreign language confused
the history teacher ventures outside to
interrogate the soldiers but he is
immediately shot and killed soon the
soldiers begin firing at the school
causing havoc throughout the area they
pelt the place with bullets and even
missiles killing several students inside
meanwhile as matt and his friends robert
danny daryl aardvark search for a way to
escape jed arrives with his car the boys
immediately get in and together they
flee from the place by this time the
entire city of kalame has come under
attack the enemy soldiers are killing
innocent people for apparently no reason
and numerous buildings are laid to waste
with heavy artillery amidst the
destruction jed and the group somehow
managed to reach robert's father's
sporting goods store there the old man
suggests they immediately leave the
place and head to the mountains as the
condition is very severe right now the
boys are hesitant to leave their
families but they have no choice but to
agree they soon grab weapons ammunition
and other necessities for survival after
stocking up they get inside the car and
head to the mountains on their way they
come across a roadblock manned by soviet
troops who opened fire on them
fortunately a helicopter from the u.s
army shoots the troops allowing the
group to make their way out in the next
scene we get to know that the soviet
troops along with cubans and nicaraguans
are attempting to take over kalame city
and then the entire nation in short
world war iii has taken place meanwhile
a cuban colonel named bella orders his
men to go to a local sporting goods
store and obtain records of the store's
gun sales on the other hand the boys
reach the mountains and start living
there since jed and matt are regular
campers in the area they have no
problems adjusting with days passing by
the group survives by fishing hunting
and even eating the vegetation there
after a few weeks jed matt and robert
sneak back into the city which is now
under the total control of the enemy
soldiers they enter a grocery store and
inquire about their families to which
the shopkeeper responds that everyone
considered a threat has been imprisoned
in a re-education camp the shopkeeper
also warns the boys to stay away as the
soldiers had been looking for them later
the boys reached the camp which is a
large area confined by a cage after a
bit of inquiring jed and matt finally
meet their father who appears to be
badly beaten they also learned that
their mother was killed by the soldiers
expectantly the boys become emotional
but the father reminds them of how he
raised them in a tough manner and
encourages them to avenge their mother's
death meanwhile robert is unable to find
his father in the camp following this
they go to their neighbor mr mason's
house who is very glad to see them again
the old man reveals that robert's father
was executed because his store was
missing a few weapons actually the
weapons are the same ones that jed and
his boys took to the mountains this
breaks robert's heart and he blames
himself for his father's death but the
guys quickly calm him down later mr
mason takes the boys to the basement and
reveals his granddaughters tony and
erica who appear to be hiding from the
troops he then requests the boys escort
the girls to a safe location to which
they agree after a while jed and his
group mount on their horses and make
their way to the mountains one day daryl
notices three soviet soldiers
approaching the mountains so he
immediately alerts the rest of the group
upon reaching the place the soldiers
start taking photographs while standing
on the edge of a cliff while they're at
it they notice some arrows on the ground
and begin searching the area soon after
they discover jed and his group hiding
behind the rocks the soldiers proceeded
to apprehend the kids but little did
they know that the kids were armed and
dangerous in no time they managed to
execute the three soldiers following the
incident colonel bella confronts daryl's
father the mayor of calumet and inquires
about his son daryl's father attempts to
save his son by claiming that he is not
violent and cannot harm others he also
tries to appease colonel bella in order
to save the innocent citizens but it all
goes in vain the next day colonel bella
gathers some civilians from the
re-education camp including jed and
matt's father and executes all of them
to exact vengeance when the youth group
learns of the death of their family
members they are devastated however jed
tells them to not give up and encourages
them to fight for their nation the next
day the youth group comes up with a plan
and erica goes to a gas station where
some soviet soldiers are filling up
their tanks she approaches the soldiers
and casually leaves a bag containing
explosives the soldiers simply flirt
with the girl and send her away but
shortly after an explosion occurs
killing a few men enraged the remaining
soldiers pursue erika and as they are
about to reach her the youth group
emerges from the ground and shoots the
soldiers to death this gives the group
renewed motivation and from that day
onwards they start executing the enemy
forces with available arms and
ammunition they also give themselves the
alias wolverines the movie then fast
forwards by a month where the enemy
troops are still in control of the city
one day tony discovers andrew tanner a
lieutenant colonel of the united states
air force dozing off near the camp when
she realizes that andrew belongs on
their side she brings him to the camp
and provides him with some food andrew
then updates them on the status of the
war he claims that the nuclear strikes
have destroyed several american cities
including omaha washington and kansas he
goes on to say that the enemies mostly
cubans came up from mexico illegally and
infiltrated the sac bases wreaking havoc
the soviet armies have captured most of
southern america and northwest canada
but american armies have been able to
stop them at rocky mountains and the
mississippi river and the lines are now
mostly stabilized according to andrew
the russians are there to capture
american armies intact which is why they
will no longer use nukes americans will
also not use nuclear weapons on their
own soil furthermore he shares that his
family was caught behind the lines down
in texas he likes to believe that his
family is still alive but he has also
heard about what the soviets are doing
to civilians the next day andrew joins
the wolverines in one of their conquests
he assists them with his military
techniques and soon the group takes down
a large number of soviet soldiers in
this way the group starts taking out
more and more enemy soldiers they have
also amassed a large arsenal of weapons
in the next scene andrew explains his
plan to take over a soviet-based camp
the group is amazed by how detailed and
smart andrew's elaborations are later
the wolverines carry out the plan and
attack the soviet base camp from all
sides eventually leading them to victory
however their actions attract the
attention of a soviet general who orders
retaliation against the innocent
civilians now that the soviet high
command is aware of the wolverines the
soviet general orders the soldiers to
eliminate the wolverines as soon as
possible elsewhere the wolverines are
enjoying a rugby match after their
victory while tony is chatting with
andrew she inquires about his wife
mentioning that she's curious about his
love life tony enjoys andrew's company
and seems to be attracted towards him
the next day the wolverines reach a high
point in the mountain where they witness
the soviet aircraft in a state of war
against the americans while watching the
chaos unfold from a distance two soviet
tanks approach from behind as a result
the wolverines quickly take their cover
behind a rock and begin shooting at them
when the enemies begin to take the upper
hand andrew and aardvark board a tank
for counter-attack but they're fatally
shot leaving the rest of the group
devastated tony appears to be even more
heartbroken because she adored andrew
before any further casualties take place
jed fires a bazooka at the enemies and
kills them once and for all following
the incident the wolverines bury andrew
and aardvark's bodies and pray for their
soul's peace one day the soviets deploy
a spetsnaz unit into the mountains and
they use portable tracking devices to
locate the wolverines despite this the
wolverines who were well prepared for
their arrival attack and defeat them
easily they then capture the spetsnaz's
leader along with all of their weapons
later the group interrogates this bets
nazis leader about their plans but the
latter refuses to reveal anything he
continues speaking in russian yet
manages to say go to hell yankees in
perfect english this enrages the group
and they execute him without any
hesitation damn they must be mets fans
following this the group examines the
dead bodies of the enemy forces and
finds the portable tracking device they
discover that the tracking device is
pointing at daryl indicating that he is
the source of it jed confronts daryl who
then admits that the soviets apprehended
him after his father turned him in he
goes on to say that the soviets forced
him to swallow a tracking chip before
releasing him to join the wolverines
daryl begs for his life but robert who
learns that the others don't have guts
to kill their own friend shoots him for
his betrayal later the wolverines reach
a new location from which they can keep
an eye on a group of soviet trucks
transporting food matt is about to fire
a rocket launcher at the soldiers but
just then the soldiers unknowingly drop
some food boxes the wolverines who are
starving at this point decide to abort
their mission so that they can retrieve
the food and eat it voraciously they
appear to be happy to eat normal food
after such a long time however their
happiness is short-lived as the soviet
helicopters swiftly approach them the
wolverines catch wind of the impending
danger but it is too late in no time
they are pelted with heavy fire causing
tony to be shot although severely
outnumbered the group still manages to
fight back soon after jed carries tony
on the horse and all of them begin to
escape in the process robert manages to
take down one of the helicopters but he
is soon executed by another one
meanwhile jed realizes that tony won't
survive for long so he places her behind
a rock the two then talk about the state
of their friendship and how war can
ravage an entire nation after a while
tony expresses her desire to go out on
her own rather than being killed by the
soviets she requests jed for a grenade
and after a lot of convincing he agrees
he hands her a live grenade and leaves
the place following this the rest of the
wolverines escape the place after some
time the soviet soldiers and their
general exit the helicopter and begin
searching for the dead bodies of the
wolverines soon after one of the
soldiers discovers tony's body and
confirms her death in this process the
grenade falls from tony's grasp causing
an explosion that takes the soldier's
life later that night the wolverines
devise a plan in which jed and matt
decide to attack the soviet headquarters
in calamei their goal is to distract the
soldiers so that danny and erica can
escape the city and live a life without
fear erica tries to convince jed that
she too wants to join in the attack but
jed tells her that someone has to
survive wasting no time the two brothers
head towards the headquarters and begin
firing at the soldiers they are able to
kill several soldiers but after a while
matt gets shot in the chest by a soviet
army commander jed takes down the
commander but he also gets injured in
the process later while a distraught jet
is carrying his brother away they are
spotted by colonel bella however when he
senses their loss he allows them to
leave that makes no sense the two
brothers then sit in a park and
reminisce about their childhood days
slowly both of them pass away holding
each other on the other hand danny and
erica trek through the rocky mountains
until they reach america's safe haven in
the last scene we see a partisan rock
and american flag nearby indicating the
victory of america in the partisan rock
it is mentioned in the early days of
world war iii guerrillas mostly children
placed the names of their lost upon this
rock they fought here alone and gave up
their lives so that this nation shall
not perish from the earth subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching